depuis vegas aussi il ya toujours une
personne a un chat noir qui n'a pas ses
bagages à votre avis donc il s'agit
hashtag bagages attaque voilà qui n'a
pas eu son bagage il y en a un qui
cherche le chef des bagages
désespérément garde
[Musique]
ça
ce que vous êtes content non non c'est à
temps d'attenté de questeur mettre à ma
place avec qu'on lit dans cette chambre
qu'est ce que j'ai fait pour avoir ça
alors et chérie maximum mais aussi à
droite a pas dix ans je promets à paris
tout va bien et l'autre maintenant
l'abattement 52e 2 de valises pas
possible la mine pour des voix cassée
par ici une fois pour une beauté
badji par email redac.thann alice n'est
pas là ils sont paumés ma valise
en plus c'est pas ma valise c'est la
valise de fatou qu'on avait spécialement
remontée de la cavb apprenez vos valises
y'a d'quoi commandes à sa valise et j'ai
la bonne série de photos qui montrent
leur vrai ça lui a valu de fatou kandé
sa valise
ça fait mal c'est la veille tout à fait
ok pas là bas mais la valise de fil ça
me gêne oui mais avec leur humour là ça
me gêne chargé
[Musique]
bonsoir
merci m
[Musique]
m
methylgene partage en jeu
[Musique]
eh oui
m
c'est l'amour
bien présente terminator india qu'est ce
qui l'a amené au n ya plus rien dans la
valise regarde
parce qu'elle est dominant l'important
je
autre question que 200 équipes chef là
dedans c'est qu'ils cherchent qui est le
chef des bagages qui est le chef des
bagages n'en rajoute pas mettre des
jacqueries super remontée contre le chef
des bagages j'ai un maxime qui veut
m'aider avec isabelle isabelle encore
mais si maxime fait un pas de plus jeune
qui a du bagage qui est le chef grains
qui est le chef d bagasse
qui est le chef des bagages
[Musique]
aussi qui elle s'était bailliage qui est
le web des bagages
le chef des malades qu'elles sont déjà
pas ici
devant le gagnant avec maxime il ya rien
qui soit organisé
qui est le chef des bagages est ce que
tu fais de zone qui est fondamentale et
à faire ton m'étonnais truc quoi genou
mais des dossiers maximum et en
pourrissant bagages peut faire insiste
alain psychologique
[Applaudissements]
avant j'ai tout fouillé d'erreurs
c'est un choix à faire et à toi ah bah
écoute possible ça je vais t'aider à
porter qui sait si c'est si tu voles qui
confirme que c'est à toi pour intégrer
les porteurs d'un tel message très fort
nous ne lâchons pas mais parce qu'elle
est il y avait des trucs dedans tu as tu
oublies
ce débat était vraiment angoissé parce
que c'était les veaux si c'était une
valise de famille comme le jogging
matthieu delormeau c'est la bête fait
valises que fatto m'avait prêté à sanaa
n'avait remonté de la cave et où on me
dit si tu la ramènes pas ça va chauffer
les débits aucune raison c'est à perdre
isaksson av
[Applaudissements]